but i think we need each other so i i
don't believe in equal rights and equal
strength and equal everything
by the way it's a falsehood it's the
biggest false
narrative that we have today yeah there
is a man
who was looking at me and looking at me
and looking at me and in me i said
i'm sure he allah knows he's probably
like what is this woman whatever
and then allah that man comes and sits
next to me
says i said if i see you and i know what
size
dress you are wearing then you need to
look at
maybe you are not following exactly what
allah wants he was a priest
yes so you're hit this is a priest
sitting next to you on the plane
and thank you for asking me to be on the
d-show yeah
inshaallah you had a blessed ramadan yes
yes alhamdulillah so we'll get uh right
into it i wanted to
go ahead and there is a
a big movement now that and it's
interesting that it's not from muslims
it's actually from non-muslims
but if you look at it you would think
that it has much more in common with
islam
so i'm going to show i'm going to show
you a video
and we'll get your reaction to it
feminist get off my app
femininity is what the gentlemen are
looking for on my app and you're going
to have
much more success on my app um
femininity is
so powerful and amazing
and awesome you don't think you can be
feminine and a feminist no
how come it's an oxymoron what about the
definition of a feminist is just someone
who believes in equal rights between men
and women
i don't believe in equal rights between
men and women how come absolutely not i
work with navy seals
you think i could keep up with those
guys no and nor would i want to can i
shoot a gun absolutely do i sleep with a
gun i do
a glock and i have an ar but could i
keep up with those guys
no i couldn't and nor do i want to
profess to
but can i teach them things in certain
arenas and i do
but i think we need each other so i
don't believe in equal rights and equal
strength and equal everything
by the way it's a falsehood it's the
biggest false
narrative that we have today if you're a
feminist get off my app
femininity is what okay so what's your
reaction when you see that
what are the first things that come to
your mind
um
as you said it's very interesting it's
coming from a non-muslim
because this is what islam is all about
it is i think we are abusing words
i don't know why we have to use the word
femininity
or feminism allah said it's clearly in
the quran and i always say this to
myself before anyone else
any issue we have current
related to religion outside religion we
need as muslims go back to the source
go back to the source and what is our
sources our sources is the quran
and our source is the sunnah right
is there anywhere there that does say
the woman has to go and fight for her
right
does it anywheres clearly explicitly say
that the man is better than the woman
and even the there is
and i know i'm sure you're gonna ask
about it these verses in the quran
people misuse it and abuse it and they
don't understand it
so i actually say maybe a little bit
different i don't need feminism
islam gave me my right but
my right doesn't mean i have to do
exactly everything the man does
why why do i look to myself my
value is what allah gave it to me
is not what the society tell me your
value
you are valuable if you can do what the
man can do
did you get my point absolutely yeah
yeah and i think and i actually i
remember one time i got this question
a huge crowd of women
and i said listen i'm an ob gyn and i
deliver babies
so the woman delivered the baby so if
the man doesn't deliver the baby is the
man less
the man has to go and look for his right
and then the mother of breastfeed and
then allah said
that the meaning of islam tells us
the the the heavens is under the feet of
the woman
when he was asked about that when the
companion asked him
who's the person who has most right upon
me
when he said um your mother your mother
your mother does the father have tungla
then your father so the father now has
to go and look for his rights
did he see the point yes the point
is not is not what i do the man has to
do or what the man does i have to do
no because we are different we are
created differently
physiology but we are equal
in rights and obligations
and places in the quran he and when he
doesn't separate
that means it's equal i will be rewarded
as a mother
the husband will not be rewarded because
he did
or will not be rewarded because he did
not breastfeed no
allah is not going to ask him about that
he's going to be rewarded
being taking care of the family see this
is the point
but i it has to be if he says this i
have to do this
honestly this is my personal opinion i
thought i found it degrading to women
now you gave you gave a measuring stick
you mentioned something the quran and
sunnah
do you think now that our compass has
kind of gotten off and we're using the
society and culture we live in
and this push and that is as
and we exclude shaytan also that this
can a deliberate attempt to try to
destroy us to separate us
to have us fighting against each other
and we're trying to compete in the wrong
ways
and now we use that our society and
culture there's some good
there but a lot of things conflict with
the deen and now our measuring stick
like your measuring stick you said
go back to the verbatim word of god
almighty the quran and the way
of the last and final measure problem
muhammad peace and blessings be upon
that's our measuring stick
but are we measuring meaning our morals
our responsibilities
you know what's right and wrong
according to the wrong measuring stick
no no you're you're getting to uh the
most
important point it's not only in the
feminism movement
it is everywhere brother eddie
everywhere huh
in in our daily life a man a woman a
child
a worker a physician a broadcaster
are we living by that measuring stick
are we no unfortunately so painful
it is so painful and that's why i love
this
this statement of saying omar
when he said the meaning of it
islam we are nation that we
we are dignified and became dignified by
islam
but we looked for dignity somewhere else
and then we became humiliated so when i
say
do i do this this movement is because we
are away from the quran on the sunnah i
will say
the first thing the main problem or i
think it's one of the most important
problem
that we in general in our lives not
living by the quran of the sunnah is we
don't understand it
we don't look at it as this is
the right path you know when
when someone very healthy
right and they fully believe drinking
eight classes of
glasses of water is very healthy
whatever other people tell them they say
nope
and you can apply this on anything in
life i think we as muslims
man and a woman needs to bring back
the convention and the certainty they
are keen
inside us that this is
the best way because the creator of me
and you and everything in this earth
knows what's best for me and you i think
this
is the problem so when we don't have the
source
we don't understand it we don't think
it's important we don't pay attention to
it
and it is not easy to follow it now that
you have to remember this
it's not easy to wake up at four a.m in
the morning and pray your father it's
much easier to sleep till seven
or eight so then when comes the other
option
which is the easiest way shaytaan
absolutely comes in
his servants comes in and then we fall
to it and then the glamour around us you
have to know
the impact of the glamour we are having
around us
everything in the social media look how
beautiful it is now but there also has a
lot of negative
and the impact and we are not well
equipped
not even the half of the quran the
person who memorized the quran
how much is he really he or she is
carrying it
you know what i'm saying applying it
so it's it's um it's a tough situation
but there is always hope and i am very
positive person always yeah
in everything there is here in it we
have to
that's that's one of the things that
allah loves that his slaves be
optimistic right they were exactly
we think the best of our creator and we
tried to make the best out of every
circumstance
when you're watching this video now when
you see like
when they're defining terms like the one
lady's saying
uh to be more feminine uh to
and you see more and more women talking
about this
because and then there's a fight between
the two uh
one is one is is feeling like she has to
fight for some certain rights and we
know islam
has elevated the status of the human
being especially the
the uh the woman we like you mentioned
earlier you know paradise being under
the feet of the mother
you know uh there's such a high level of
respect given you know
to to women in the dean uh to women just
in general
but now a woman is made to look
down upon if she chooses to now
pursue let's say uh knowledge of the
dean uh
first and foremost following the first
verses that were revealed
she looks at that like more as like
that's knowledge of my lord and my deen
first rather than let's say chasing a
career she wants to do it from home and
she wants to be a home engineer
but the society and now there are women
who are pushing and saying
don't make these women look like they're
less they're accomplishing less because
they want to be
raising their their children and also at
the same time from their home they want
to be seeking knowledge
right they don't they they chose that
rather than to be let's say
in the corporate world or whatnot and
and she's feeling sometimes it's a
struggle she's feeling guilty because of
that the society
are you have you are you seeing this
also that's affecting me
absolutely it's affecting the woman let
me just
uh go back a little bit to be fair
to be feared is there injustice
against the woman inside the homes
i'm not saying i'm saying is it not
necessarily every home
and i'm not talking about us living in
the states i'm talking about in general
in the world
the the answer is absolutely yes and i
think
when an extreme happens the reaction is
another extreme
you know what i'm saying so when you
tell for example that the
daughters cannot go to college they
cannot pursue any knowledge
but the boy can the response will be you
know what
what we're now talking about is feminism
so to tackle this problem
is equality what allah gave us
and equality in looking at
the if you want to call it the job so i
give you an example when i see my
patients in the office
and as you know i'm an ob gyn so i deal
always with the woman
and i ask her what do you do and she
said i'm just uh
i'm just i'm just staying home this is
look at the answer
i'm just staying home my response just
staying home you have the best
profession in the world
you're a mother we don't look at
motherhood
as a profession because we define the
profession what brings me money
or what brings me status in dunya in
life
you know and this is not only in this
i'll share with you
it's an a beautiful incident happened
with me in ramadan
and this is an amazing beautiful young
lady
mother of two who is half hiv
highly educated called me crying
and she was saying i cannot read i need
to read my five
of the quran to review the five parts
because otherwise i'll forget
but i don't i cannot do it you know and
my response to her
why do you think allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
or actually what do you think allah at
this point when he put you as a mother
as a wife in ramadan where
is your main act of worship is it in
leaving your children and husband
and responsibility and reviewing five
of the quran then you misunderstood
ibadah you misunderstood the act of
worship
the act of worship when allah put you in
a position
he puts you in you become the best
abd servant of allah in that position
now these are both
highly imp it's not dunya but i told her
take care of your children breastfeed
them
give them the love they need take care
of your husband take care of
care of your home whatever time left you
review the quran i said minimum at least
one jesus a day
then you are in the sight of allah as as
one of the beautiful spiritual imams
used to say
stand where allah puts you not where you
want to be
so don't look down because this is how
we look at it
i'll give you another example if you
allow me even outside woman
even men right and i say this to all my
friends
so if your son decided to go and pursue
islamic knowledge
and he wants to become an imam versus he
wants to
he and he declined acceptance in medical
school
what do you think the response of the
family
it's a culture it's it's so sad
it's because we value things
by the money yeah yeah how much
they pay you i i will give you this
example
and this is not example this is true
incident happened to me when i was
studying overseas islamic studies and i
was also working
as an obgyn so i remember very well i
went in the middle of the night to
deliver a baby
and i took my book of because i had
tomorrow an exam
and sometimes labor delivery takes long
time so i said if i have time i'll
review
a colleague of mine muslim
right came in looked at the book picked
up the book and says
why are you doing this to yourself how
much more they will pay you
did you get the point when we the
measure
the measure is the material measure
when the success is the success of dunya
of this life
if the success is how much like and
followers we have
not much how much followers and like
allah
has for us the whole thing changes
there's uh many stories that are written
and they are again
even not by muslims uh because sometimes
i'll quote the
non-muslims or not yet muslim sources
because sometimes for people
it just hits more home because now
they're just saying oh you're just
pushing deen on me you just put you know
religion well hold on this is a reality
where for instance
there was an article being written by
many
uh women who were in getting up in age
and they had accomplished on the wall
they had their phds
they had all this the certificates but
they had not pursued the family life
uh meaning they were in in late in age
and they weren't able to get married now
they put this off
and they weren't able to have kids uh
they missed that opportunity from the
fertility window
and now they were talking about how they
were themselves testifying
that now they were into such a state of
loneliness and despair
because yeah they achieved let's say the
phd
but they didn't have children they
didn't get married and they were
living the last years of their life in
such depression
and if they can go back they would have
definitely
picked more of the way that islam is
encouraging
you know you know uh husband and wife
coming together
being married obviously chasing i mean
uh knowledge in the right way
and in the right condition so when have
you heard a lot of these stories also
yes and i'll tell you my answer
my answer is absolutely different than
what you shared because our lens
we look at things back again to the
source yeah
everything is from allah so when the
woman
tells me and actually we had this
discussion recently
with a group of of women and i said
don't look at yourself if you did not
become a mother
that you are less or if you are have
five children but you did not pursue
your career you're less i'm gonna say
this again
it's whatever allah choose because
it's not our choices however
if you by choice said i don't want to
get married
because i want to have my career
my answer to the muslim woman have you
prayed this tihara
did you ask allah for this and if allah
showed you
that this man or that man is not the
best for you then that means he doesn't
want you to be a mother
who is much better than a seida aisha
who
any woman other than say the hadith
do we know she was not a mother right
that doesn't mean she is less subhan
allah but allah subhanallah
used her in a different way so i always
and again i'm going to say what i said
to you earlier
where allah put you so you always ask
guidance from allah this is why if you
see i don't know if you
listen to the teachings and the lectures
i give
and even the courses we have i always
stress on this
because this is when i learned it as a
human being let alone as a woman
everything in life changed everything
comes from allah
let it be do what pleases allah
not what pleases you as a person or what
pleases people let it be yeah allah you
don't want me to have children
i'm fine with that career this is the
usual
the usual debate
internal debate in the woman career
versus family
yeah right and if i look at the man and
you tell me if i'm wrong
is it my career versus my deen
because the career takes a lot of my
time i don't really have enough time to
pursue
my my what i want even my salah my daily
act of worship so this is what i tell
the woman for the man the answer is
obvious as long as you have enough
your deen has to balance but for the
woman
wait both can be act of worship
let allah choose for you don't let
society
dictate on you what is good or bad
let allah tells you motherhood is
amazing
state but to say that aisha was not a
mother
and what a state she had and i say this
was a mother but what a state she had
did he get my point yeah
let not the society dictate on us
what is right or wrong in everything let
it be allah and the rasulallah
yeah so where i'm i'm picking up on
specifics but
usually the root of it it goes back to a
lot of times what you're talking about
is us not devoting more time to learning
our deen and
what our creator wants from us and
indulging more
in learning the quran and sunnah and and
from people of knowledge
then we can be more informed and have a
better measuring stick
so then our moral compass will be more
on tuned uh
there's an some things be and then
sometimes from these specifics sometimes
maybe a light bulb
can go off because sometimes there'll be
just obvious things that person to think
about for instance
like there are certain injunctions for
the man and for the woman
uh and here we're talking more
specifically because we have a
a scholar in islam that you know
specifically can
talk to some of our sisters uh because
there's a lot of confusion out there and
whatnot so when allah out of his love
he tells both of us to do something and
then a person rebels
but then they'll go to work and then
they'll obey the boss
and they'll put on a certain you know
let's say
um an outfit or whatnot and go through
all of the hardship and everything
to get make to chase the career and the
money and then obey the boss
but then we we fail in obeying allah
the creator of the heavens and earth
i'll tell you what i may have to add to
what you said
or maybe rephrase it yes and this is
going to all the sisters
and this is going to all the brothers
also the question is can i obey allah
dress properly the way it pleases allah
and can i be
quote unquote if you want to use career
woman
can i be a successful woman in my career
but still obeying allah
most of the time the answer is yes and
i'm speaking now from personal
experience you will need
to put your foot down
and put allah's obedience number one
so let's say there is a party
christmas party in the and this is our
life here
right my question comes in is this is
obedience to allah or this is not
not if the answer is not i'm not going
well shaytaan is going to come and tell
me well you will lose your job my answer
is
allah is the one who gives me the job
you put your your pain and certainty in
allah
obey him and absolutely can get your
career
if he wants you to be in that and i am
an example here i am i am a career woman
i'm an ob gyn
i have my my own practice
right people tells me yes if you have
done this or that you probably would
have gone
get this and that my answer is my focus
is not my dunya my focus is my akhirah
and alhamdulillah allah gave me a lot of
what other people want
so my advice to the sisters and the
brothers if you allow me
always put allah's obedience and
pleasure number one
and remember this statement it's a
hadith
the meaning of if you leave anything for
allah
allah will replace it with something
better
you leave it you don't do it you like it
people tell you that's probably the best
thing for your career you leave it
because it's not pleasing to allah
allah will give you allah will give you
better than it
whether internally you will feel much
happier
or whether internally and externally so
let's put it this way in the quran and
i'm going to say it in a different way
those who sell their dunya
they sold their their hereafter for the
dunya
let's us not be of these people period
let's put allah's pleasure number one
and i said to allah there is no
happiness
whatever your bank account tells you
whatever position you have
man or a woman there's no happiness
unless
you are have this correct beautiful
relationship with allah
and peace comes in internally what's the
difference when you have someone who is
going
in a particular field and that's to
benefit
the ummah where there's a lack let's say
you want obviously you know a man who
has rita
he wants someone like you to deliver his
his wife's you know this is part of our
a man's nature
don't want another man delivering i mean
you you even if you have to drive to
another state wherever the case
so we want it we need let's say uh a
doctor like you you're you're benefiting
the ummah right this is this is
something that's needed
uh as opposed to someone who is going
and now let's just give an extreme
example and then you can fill in between
if there's
other but someone who wants to now
compete and say we need more
mma fighters right a woman wants to be
or a boxer or to be out and competing
with men or construction worker out
there
and now it's not fulfilling a niche
where it's needed for a community
but now it's more it's the line of just
competing
with the man even though both men and
men or women shouldn't be
in these a lot of these sports and box
you know these things but i'm just
giving an example where sometimes
to to differentiate the line where a you
have an area that's needed
right and to benefit the community and
over here to differentiate where it's
just for
myself and then i put myself in an
uncomfortable situation like you had
this whole
metoo movement where now they even
changed the laws
i mean they changed a lot of the company
statuses where
uh having these late night meetings with
men going to their you know
leaving alone they changed this where
it's more in line with the dean but
now you chase this career where you're
in such you have to be in uncomfortable
situations mixing with the opposite
gender and you put your dean
in a very you put yourself in a tight uh
risky
situation i'll tell you i'll tell you
what brother
uh brother eddie even as an ob gyn when
i did my residency
right and here i go so let's start from
the beginning
woman should be delivered by woman the
answer is yes as long as the woman who
is delivering you
is as qualified is not she's not
qualified or your case is very
complicated and there is a man who is
much more qualified
or a non-muslim woman who is much more
qualified then that's no doubt about it
and that's the deen
that's what we taught however to get to
that point
do i need to go through some of what you
said the answer is yes
i i did my residency and there was i was
surrounded by men
most of the attendings were men half of
my colleagues were men
right but remember your conduct
you are a muslim woman you know what i'm
saying
this is what i keep to reminding people
keep your identity as a muslim woman or
a muslim man
if they are saying things is not
pleasing to allah i'm not going to be
part of it
because i'm a muslim if they are
doing things disobedience to allah i'm
not going to be even there
so it is i have to be in reality
but also i have to put the barrier it is
my religion
it is not allowed it's going to be very
difficult in the beginning i am speaking
to you from my heart brother eddie
and and whoever is listening to me is
this easy
absolutely not you may get difficulty
absolutely yes
you may lose opportunities yes but to
allah and i'm saying this again
you do it to please allah don't sell
your deen
properly they will respect you more put
your hijab they will respect you more
and i'm sharing with you another
personal but sometimes personally
real right when i applied for my ob gyn
at that time it was
extremely competitive especially for
a non-us graduate dr eunice so
tell us what can a person do to get that
motivation
because when you're grounded in your
deen
this is the most important thing again
going back to how we started to have you
make the right decisions you're always
connected to your creator law
you're more informed less chances of
shakedown misleading you
what can you give of advice to have
someone more motivated
to really starting your day with dean
and in between
cutting out a lot of the things that are
just a waste of time
you know taking the mothers of the
believers as role models
rather than the kim kardashian show i
don't know if you've heard of these
i have to i give talks i have to be up
to date
yeah you got to be up to date but it's a
sad reality sometimes we're taking the
wrong people as examples
so what what do you like to uh say to
motivate people
to really get grounded in the deen i'll
tell you what brother eddie
is what's what's made me what's made me
learn learn and learn
learn about your creator learn about
allah
his majesty everything he does
perfection his wisdom the more you learn
about allah
the more you'll find everything
much less significant i wouldn't say
insignificant
but much less significant and your goal
and i'm not saying this these things you
don't read it you don't learn it in
books brother
you don't these things you have to feed
it
and that's why one of my teachers is
always to say there is
tawheed you you bear witness there is no
god by allah and you say it by your
tongue
and there is the real one that you see
it with your heart
you see that allah is operating learn
learn about allah
give yourself and this if you see the
icon
in our skype give yourself some time
this summer to learn
to learn and i always joke with the
ladies and i say if i'm gonna ask you
for a recipe now
from from your mind you most of you will
give me that recipe but if i'm gonna ask
you
tell me how many how many surahs in the
quran just give me the number
how many of you will give me the right
answer
knowledge knowledge knowledge the first
i the first verse allah the my creator
and yours
send it to us
let us not spend our time most of it i
wouldn't say
we need some time to breathe but let's
not spend most of the day on she said
he said follow the social media
whatsapp whatever go out drink coffee do
this
these are waste of time allah will ask
us about the time
one of the things we will be asked
especially youth
what did you do with your time and
energy
learn start and i will say this to
everybody listening to me
we have no excuse this day and age when
we are going to be standing in front of
allah
what will i tell him i there was no one
to teach me
there is no resources i didn't have an
internet who doesn't have a phone now
who doesn't have an access to youtube
who doesn't have
an access to download books it's just i
don't have the
the desire i don't look at it as
important that's what needs to be
changed
number one learn about allah number two
learn about death and that's what
rasulallah
kept reminding his companions
remind yourself plenty of the destroyer
of joy he didn't call it death because
the moment you see someone dying or dead
or you're burying him
do you really care about what car you
are driving which
is it going with him to the grave
remember this
and think of the achira think of the
hereafter
this is temporary i am moving to new
york
i'm not going to build the house in
saint louis and i'm going to put all my
energy in st
clues that's where i live now because
i'm going to new york
and if you see someone doing this you
say are you out of your mind that's how
it
is that's how it is re that's why we
have the morning
and the evening at car you probably know
that
why it's in the morning it's in the
evening you start your day with fajr
salah and afterward
is 10 15 minutes remember him but look
at what it is
i am pleased with allah as my lord the
more you do this and this is not a one
day
it's not a switch i always tell people
it's not a switch you just turn it on
this is a process a lot of dua to allah
allah allah make your love more beloved
to me
than the love of everything else we had
this
whole in ramadan we did the whole series
about the love of allah
every day something allah loves and if i
do
something allah loves he will love me
and if he will love me
he will take me out from all this
superficial love
to the real love learn remember death
look at the achira and a lot of vicar of
allah
including dua for yourself who doesn't
want to have the best home
who doesn't ask anyone around you rich
or poor
why do i only want to have a good home
in dunya why not the best house in
africa
in general for those highest level and
my neighbor is
change the way we look at things and
give
do and i say this to myself do yourself
a favor one of the people i used to know
actually i still know used to send
herself he's a woman
every morning a reminder you know the
reminders we send out ourselves on the
phone
do you know what's the reminder brother
eddie
please don't disobey allah
that carefully
bring the muslims back to their
beautiful deen in a beautiful way
in a beautiful return
that's how it is look at it not as a
complimentary
look at the deen as the essence look at
your relationship with allah is number
one
everything else comes next and that's
how they lived
yes last question have you ever had an
encounter with a
a non not yet muslim i always say not
yet muslim because everyone has the
potential to submit to their creator
that's what a muslim is one who submits
his or her will
to god almighty the creator allah and
have you had an
encounter where they asked you about
your hijab
and many people don't know that you're
imitating mary the
medium uh mary the mother of jesus and
any most of the pictures that are out
there obviously we don't have her
literal picture but
they're betraying you someone who looks
like you what do you tell them when they
have has that work
or has anyone questioned you or or
have you had a discussion about it how
do you respond
i'll tell you what um
recently it's becoming much less and
less because becoming more
known that this is a muslim but i'll
give you a true story please this is
insane
incident happened to me last year yeah i
was flying before the kobe of course
i was flying and as i we were waiting
uh there is a man who was looking at me
and looking at me and looking at me
and in me i said i'm sure he allah knows
he's probably
like what is this woman whatever and
then
allah that man comes and sits next to me
in the plane and it's one hour and a
half
and one and a half hour is all this
discussion he turned to be a priest
he was a priest yes so you're he this is
a priest sitting next to you on the
plane
and he was he look how it started
and he and he was uh after this you're
living in this or living in that and he
said
you probably noticed i was looking at
you in the waiting room
in the uh um waiting area and i said yes
i did
and he said i asked myself is she
a christian catholic
or she may be and then he said no no no
i said i think she's a muslim
and all the discussions start he
immediately you know what he said
he said what you are wearing reminded me
of mary so i didn't have to
i didn't have to say anything so that
you didn't even have to say nothing the
christian priest
he looks at you and said what you're
wearing is reminding me of obviously
jesus is mother mary
exactly yeah the christian priest told
you this wow exactly
and then we went and the whole
discussion was actually about women
rights
in islam it's amazing amazing absolutely
people ask me
right and and sisters ask me muslims ask
me
why do you do it my first answer
and i want everyone to listen to me
listening to me
learn this and may allah put it in your
heart as he put it in mind
and i say and you say why you are
wearing your head cover
or while you're wearing your islamic
attire i say because allah asked me to
do it
period and then they say is it a choice
this is the second question you always
get and i said
it's your choice and mine to obey allah
or not to obey him
and i i need to get be ready at the day
of judgment when i'm standing in front
of him
and i better prepare a very good answer
why i chose
not to obey him so
you know what i'm saying we really have
to look at
it's islam and and i think one of the
issues you you tackled it in the
beginning
i think it's also the way we were taught
or it is being taught
islam is a personal relationship between
you
and your creator and it's a relationship
of love
oh and there is fear and not fear from
him
subhana no it's fear of of lack of his
pleasure and love
if you look at your religion this way
so what you cover your hair so what if
you don't get this job because they
didn't give it to you
you know what i'm saying everything
becomes very trivial
so yes i've absolutely had this not
recently
and i actually love it because this is
my opportunity
i was like i love it yeah it just came
to my mind sorry last question but
what do you what do you say because
sometimes the the uh
the head covering has been limited just
to the top part
and then you'll see some unfortunately
someone might have some good intention
but it goes back to what you're saying
the proper knowledge so you have some
sister so wear this but everything else
is like a skirt or whatnot
how do you address that i get i get this
question all the time
right is makeup harom nail polish
can i wear jeans right all these
questions everybody asks it
it's not only men it's men and women and
muslims and non-muslims relevant
questions for our times yeah it's
important yeah and it is very important
yeah and my answer is you know what i
always try to avoid the word haram and
halal unless it's very clear
especially if you're talking to absolute
person who is not yet grounded
i say always look at the essence of it
what is the word hijab
right and look at it in surah nur in
chapter the light in the quran allah
said
he didn't say the word hijab there in
that context he actually says
don't show your beauty right
don't show your beauty so i tell the
woman when they tell me what should i
dress what do what do i wear i said
if you are putting anything on your body
that is showing the beauty of your body
you are not doing what allah wants done
why you're putting makeup to look more
beautiful
ex outside is that pleasing to allah is
that what he said he said
don't show your beauty nail polish same
thing
so when i and i this i say this to all
my beautiful sisters i said if i see you
and i know what size dress you are
wearing
then you need to look at maybe you are
not following exactly what allah wants
it does not describe the body you cannot
say
you cannot see through and can i be
and this is to the sisters can i be
elegant can i be modern
can i be looking beautiful in the way
pleasing to allah
the answer is absolutely yes
alhamdulillah especially these days
but again is the influences and the
priorities
may allah teach us all may allah make
things easy
for everybody for the men to practice
for the woman to practice
for the children to practice
you know this is make us love
iman make us love faith and we beautify
it in our hearts and allah
and it's because once i love something i
do it
and you know when i see someone
disobeying allah you know what's my dua
to that person she or he
ya allah take the love of this
disobedient
outside their heart because if you don't
love it you don't do it
yes
thank you so much this is why we're
sharing this information and and talking
to someone like you is because we want
the best for
all of mankind especially our brothers
and sisters out there thank you so much
for spending some time with us and
sharing all this uh
important advice it's a pleasure i loved
it alhamdulillah
may allah reward you i mean i mean heads
[Music]